we have the story from the Daily Mail
okay Former Defense official says the
U.S has recovered technology that quote
did not originate on this Earth discuss
I don't buy it they're always going to
tell us it's alien it's always a
distraction you know what the real story
is what former Defense official says he
was told by someone in government
they've discovered technology offer
technology so the Daily Mail is framing
it in such a way that it makes it sound
like he's definitively saying he was
party to it but he's actually if you
read it he's actually saying uh America
may have in our possession and that uh
he believes it happened because uh
what's the exact quote
um he says melon says he expects no
information will surface blah blah
I've been told that we have recovered
technology that did not originate on
this Earth by officials in the dod and
by former intelligence officials that
means it originated in
Antarctica's under it there was there's
a Stargate Antarctica I'm going to make
one point my grandfather was a big shot
air traffic controller in the Soviet
Union high up in the in the military I'm
not a high up whatever he's aircraft
control so there's certain levels of
clearance he told me that they would see
things that could not that yeah these
are like trained you know people it's
not just some random uh jerk on the
street if someone jerking High office he
would say they would see things on their
radar that they could not explain all
the time and this was very understood
for both sides and it wasn't
technological it was like okay this
doesn't make sense radar Distortion I
think is talking plasma or other stuff
like it right lightweight drones also
meta materials things like Aero gel um
airloin like hardcore machine material
that's lighter than air they will float
in the air yeah but okay stuff in the
vaccine is remember oh what what is it
graphene oxide yeah that stuff
and it can take any shape right graphene
it's hexagonally like honeycomb lattice
Adam thick the world is wrong you can
turn it into like you can make like uh
tubes out of it yeah it can take any
shape I mean hypothetically I don't know
if any shape is the right phrase because
Nano molecular level are you talking
about like a liquid metal yeah material
this is like Harley Quinn did you see
those videos where the um graphene is
being moved around magnetically okay or
something you're not getting this back
in the rain I want to say something in
Michael malice yes sir so it was um I I
think it was 2006 I had just stopped
working at O'Hare Airport in Chicago I
had friends who still worked there and
they confirmed this story to me
I had a friend who was uh I think he was
on his way to O'Hare I'd worked for
American Eagle Airlines a regional
Airline you can look up photos of this
the photo of the UFO exists there was a
gray
saucer shaped object that came down from
the clouds and hovered above O'Hare
above the United Express terminal which
I believe was the sea Gates I could be
wrong C or D and stayed there for a few
minutes and then shot straight up into
the clouds and punched a hole in it
uh I don't know all the clouds a hole in
the clouds leaving a hole with sunlight
coming through
and
apparently a pilot looked out and had
some like rudimentary old cell phone
with a picture he took a picture of it
somehow and the photo exists you can
Google it you can find the photo
people I knew who worked there said they
saw it people like these are on these
are regular guys right mid-40s they're
not superstitious they watch football
and they played Xbox they cared nothing
for this and they were like I don't know
what that was man and they've seen
things so they would know for something
normal and here's the crazy thing my
friend who was on his way to work said
on Mannheim Road right next to the
airport people stopped their cars in the
middle of the road got out and were
staring at it okay yeah and then we're
just like so what was it we don't know
what it was but uh uh there's it's a
famous UFO story you can read all about
it and I had left so I didn't see any of
it but I so all I can say is hearsay I
ask people who are there and they said
they saw it and they couldn't explain it
I was talking to cash Patel who oh yeah
the defense department with Trump yes I
believe so I was like do we have craft
that can go out into space and then go
under the ocean and he was like huh
can't tell you that one yeah and I was
like okay he didn't say yes so I didn't
say no he didn't say no and he looked at
me like I can't tell you they're 50
years ahead of what we know yes
laboratory that was like 100 years ago
the stuff he was working I got to point
out people have posted a lot of fake
photos there's weird CGI garbage and I
wonder if it's intentionally trying to
shut the story down so here let me pull
this up right here this is uh musings of
an Explorer College I just Googled it
and you can see this image which I
believe does look like the image I
remember I'm not sure and there's
something this is this is 2006 this is
before iPhones cell phones barely had
cameras they had really garbage cameras
and I don't know how the photo was taken
it says taking it O'Hare November 7
2006. I had just stopped working there I
think in like August and so my friends
people I knew were all still there I
called them I was like yo what is this I
heard the story crazy and uh there's
there's supposedly the image can I say
one thing just one sentence I want to
give a big Fu to Ashley Sinclair because
she told me to watch arrival and the
first two thirds of the movie awesome
and then the conclusion sucks so I
wasted two hours of my very short lit
remaining life so F you Ashley it was it
was so it was Seagate what arrival
arrival yeah it was Seagate which I
believe is United Express which was
right next to us so we I think we were D
and like H that was the American uh
American Eagle Gates so right across
would see United Express we never go
there that's their different company and
uh it was right above the sea Gates so
the craziest thing though and and you
know you read these stories and they say
12 employees saw it I'm like dude I had
a friend who worked there said the
people were getting out of their cars on
on in the middle of Manheim Road this
big you know uh State uh our local
highway and it's like that street lights
it's not like an expression and let's
talk a bit of a misinformation so yeah I
was hanging around for a while for a
couple minutes for five minutes because
like there's people who said there was a
book that was published thing in France
at the time claiming that 9 11 never
happened and that the World Trade Center
towers are Holograms right so the point
being if you have any questions about
these issues right away way there's
enough misinformation out there that's
like oh oh so you're saying that they're
Holograms and it was shot down by lasers
so a lot of times there's enough of this
nonsense that's flooded to make it seem
that anyone's asking about something you
just talked about where sane sober
daylight working class regular people
are seeing our eyewitnesses you could
sweep it all in the rug but just
accusing it of being the most extreme
version because people say no planes
flew into into yeah right yeah you know
so this would say that was cgo right
this is what bothers me about most
conspiracy theories is that they people
who engage in the most extreme thinking
on an issue actually make it impossible
right to to get to the bottom of an
issue and so I'll give you an example
when the emails got released by
Wikileaks where uh uh they started the
whole pizza gate thing someone said is
it is it more what do they say is it
better to try uh play dominoes on pizza
or on pasta one day seemingly out of
nowhere someone fabricated this idea
that these words were references to
children they were not now there are
certainly CP is a reference thing cheese
pizza was a reference thing but they
conflated this
and you know what I think it really was
what drugs yes no no I'll say one more
thing Tim it was clearly not pizza it
was clearly called for something and we
don't know what that is and then what
happened pizza for an hour right yeah
heroin ecstasy no no but it's not pizza
the point is it's not right but so
here's the issue what's something that
is entirely believable is that a bunch
of White House people were doing
hardcore schedule one drugs like cocaine
at a party and they speak in code anemic
yes that could be we could easily
investigate drug abuse and say we want
to get to the bottom of what they were
talking about doing but then all of a
sudden the internet blows up with the
most insane conspiracies and then
immediately the media says this proof
it's fake and regular people don't
question it I'm gonna say one I think
they do do that all the time but here's
the thing I don't think it's that that
insane because very publicly this
Administration killed a bunch of kids
overseas and no one even had a demotion
for it
in Afghanistan they're like oh we just
killed a bunch of kids up too bad no one
got reprimanded so I you can't think
it's too crazy that people in government
are literally killing children all the
time no no well everything that I've
said that my children I have five
children everything I've said for the
last 20 years they go godmother you and
your they call your mother
when they're pissed god mother you and
your ridiculous conspiracy theories
everything I said has came true three
years later okay every single everything
yeah when I said it was a pedo Ponzi
priesthood pyramid scheme yeah it's all
true it's coming true every day well in
four months we'll see if uh if the
tribunals happen but why are you in on
the bet Tim no I'm a fence sitter all
right I want to talk about a little bit
about anti-gravity because it's got the
stream it's a wrap you end on the high
note there's a lot of muddied water on
anti-gravity that it's impossible you
know obviously it's totally impossible I
think it is and there's something called
the Bible I feel Brown effect if you
want to look into like something that
might potentially be uh asymmetrical
capacitor thrusters and I'm wondering if
I try and do these experiments with
Jeremy riss at his laboratory in New
Jersey and we were trying to figure out
if you can increase horizontal velocity
fast enough you'll reduce Vertical
Velocity to zero and then you'll be you
won't be interacting with gravity net so
you'll be falling forward basically
overcome gravity no they don't
they use that's not what gravity means
they're not overcoming gravity but if
you can use slower trees throw up
against grab Michael the UFO is
overcoming gravity right now yeah
there's also something called ionic wind
which might be you able to use to push
metal super lightweight metal around how
do we fund a buddy comedy where they're
both cops who have to work together like
Rush Hour four we should do it hey
do you understand the words that are
coming out of my mouth now hold on hold
on let me let me say this Laboratories
you mentioned Arrow gel do you know what
Arrow gel is no I don't it's a solid
that's lighter than air and or I don't
think it's completely out of an area
it's it's it's not lighter but it floats
into the you can like it's it's a solid
and you can like tap it it will like and
it's super heat resistant you can hit it
with like blow torches and this has been
created or it's hypothetical oh they
have Arrow graphite is lighter than air
so seven times lighter than air it is
lighter than that a graphene Arrow gel
it does that graphene that's what I'm
talking about yeah this is we're going
to start pulling it out of the carbon
dioxide and then we're going to have to
figure out how not to pull too much out
because we're competing I think I hear
wedding bells let's have babies
you ready for number six
here take a look maybe maybe we can find
him
I'm not so sure it's lighter than there
because if it was lighter and except
that it's fast it's lighter would hit
the space yeah it would float it would
float to the top out of the atmosphere
right so uh I don't know if they show
but anyway it exists um
veritasium has a video on it so here's
my point yeah there it is what about
rods from God do you know about that yes
that's right that was thorium the amount
of tungsten rods the um the uh is it or
is it Palladium but the the amount of
energy required to get that into space
just is you're storing the energy and
then you have to maintain it wait what
are these rods from Gods it's a
hypothetic theoretical weapon where we
launch a Tungsten Rod into space and
then keep it in orbit and when you
release it it's ten times more power 100
times more powerful than a nuclear bomb
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time